हेलो
एवरीवन एंड फर्स्ट ऑफ ऑल वेरी गुड इवनिंग
टू
ऑल तो मुझे बताइए सबको मेरी आवाज
सुनाई दे रही है आई एम लाउड एंड
क्लियर बताइए
प्लीज हाई डिबल
क्लियर ओके थैंक यू थैंक यू थोड़ा सा वेट
करते हैं दो मिनट का क्लास के स्टार्ट
होने का मतलब कि स्टूडेंट्स के आने का
उसके बाद क्लास को हम स्टार्ट
करेंगे वेरी गुड इवनिंग अखिलेश वेरी गुड
इवनिंग प्रणय यह रेगुलर स्टूडेंट्स हैं
मेरी एक भी क्लास को मिस नहीं करते हैं
नहीं आई कांट डू इट ऑन जूम बिकॉज दिस इज अ
फ्री पेड रहती है हमारी क्लासे जूम और ग
मीट
पे य आई एम फाइन
तो थोड़ा सा वेट करते हैं हम सो
दैट कि बाकी स्टूडेंट है वह जवाइन हो
जाए उसके बाद हम क्लास को कंटिन्यू करेंगे
तो सबसे पहले मुझे बताइए कि मैंने लास्ट
क्लास में डे मतलब इससे पहले एक दिन छोड़
जो क्लास हुई थी लास्ट डे
21 उसमें मैंने आपको एक टास्क दिया था कि
बब सूट इंस्टॉलेशन कर दिया हमने उसके बाद
आपको बताया था कि आपको हिटल ट्रान करना है
और वहां पर एक वेब पेज फाइंड आउट करना है
तो किसी ने किया
उसको किसी ने उसको सॉल्व किया या किसी ने
ट्राई
किया राजू वेरी गुड इवनिंग वेरी गुड
इवनिंग जगत जगत गुरु जी मैं अच्छा हूं आप
सब बताइए कैसे हो
नहीं संभव जैन यह बिल्कुल एब्सलूट फ्री
ट्रेनिंग है हाई क्वालिटी कंटेंट के साथ
इंटरमीडिएट लेवल तक
देखिए बात ऐसी है कि आपको साइबर में शिफ्ट
करने के लिए अगर मैं सच बोलूंगा तो
नेटवर्क की नॉलेज आपको होनी
चाहिए तो बताइए किसकिस ने टास्क किया
मैं आप लोगों से जो पूछ रहा हूं आप उसका
तो आंसर करने रहे
हो संभव तो अगर आपके पास दो साल का
एक्सपीरियंस है तो आई डोंट नो कि आपने
कितना किस कंपनी में काम किया और किन किन
प काम किया
है बट डिफेंसिव और ऑफेंसिव ऑफेंसिव साइड
की भी आपको नॉलेज होनी चाहिए अगर आपने शौक
में ऑलरेडी काम किया होगा तो अदर वाइज
आपको एडवांस जाना है तो आपको फिर सीआई
एसएसपी लेवल तक जाना पड़ेगा शॉक तो
स्टार्टिंग में बिल्कुल बिगनर फेस प रहता
है उसको एडवांस करने के लिए आपको सीआई
एसएसपी की तैयारी करनी पड़ेगी उसके अलावा
उसके बाद आपको और भी ज्यादा मतलब नॉलेज
होनी चाहिए आपको बहुत कुछ होनी चाहिए उसके
लिए ओके पीछे लेक्चर का प्रैक्टिस कर रहे
हो ओके इट्स ओके
या श्यर यू कैन डू डे फोनिक फॉरेंसिक
कोर्स यस यस डेफिनेटली यू कैन डू
इट ओके क्लास को स्टार्ट करते हैं दे 25
स्टूडेंट्स तो अभी हम गो बैक टू ववर काली
मशीन और अभी हम ब्राउजर पर चलते हैं और
अपनी एजेंट सुडो की जो ट्राई हैक की
सीटीएफ उसको स्टार्ट करते हैं एक बार
एक्टिवेट करते हैं
बस मुझे दो मिनट का समय दीजिए ताकि मैं
लैब के साथ कनेक्ट कर
पाऊं और आज
हम इसको कंप्लीट ही कर लेंगे
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज क्योंकि इसके ऊपर एक
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज का मुझे कुछ
कांसेप्ट क्लियर करना आपका कुछ आपको
इंपॉर्टेंट चीज समझा है तो वह हम नेक्स्ट
क्लास में कवर करेंगे बट आज हम एक्सप्लोइट
कर लेंगे गेन एक्सेस कर लेंगे और वहां पर
आपको टास्क प्रोवाइड कर दूंगा कि आपको यह
खुद से करना है देन वहां पर एक टॉपिक है
काफी इंटरेस्टिंग और इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक है
आपके नॉलेज के लिए वह मैं आपको एक्सप्लेन
करूंगा
ओके आई विल स्टार्ट माय
मशीन जब तक हम क्या करते हैं एक बार ओपन
वीपीएन से भी कनेक्शन क्रिएट कर लेते हैं
ओके नाउ आम सक्सेसफुली कनेक्टेड टू द
ट्राई हैक म ओपन वीपीएन सर्वर इसको हम
रिनेम करते
हैं सबको हमें स्क्रीन दिखाई दे रही है या
थोड़ा सा और जूम करना है
ओके बब शूट भी स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं
हम ओके हम यहां से स्टार्ट नहीं करेंगे
ओके
ना अभी सही है
और जूम कर दूं देखो बब शूट तो जूम होगा
नहीं बट हां यह जो आपका टर्मिनल है ये जूम
हो
जाएगा तो एक बार आईपी चेक करते हैं हम ये
रहा दिस इज आवर आईपी एड्रेस नाउ वी आर
कनेक्टेड टू द ओपन वीपीएन एक बार आपको पता
है कि लास्ट टाइम हमने जब एन मैप को यूज
किया था लास्ट क्लास में हमने डिस्कस किया
था तो तीन सर्विसेस रन कर रही थी इस
पर्टिकुलर आईपी के अगेंस्ट ओके तो होल्ड
ऑन गाइज
जस्ट 10 सेकंड
ओके तो अभी हम क्या करते हैं मशीन को पिंग
करेंगे तो कोई इशू नहीं है क्योंकि मशीन
ऑलरेडी आपकी एक्टिव है तो हमने जहां पर
लास्ट क्लास में अपने क्लास को फिनिश किया
था जहां पर हमने एक टॉपिक कवर किया था कि
जो वेबसाइट क्या है ब्राउजर स्पेसिफिक हो
सकती नहीं हो सकती तो इसको हमने डिस्कस
किया था और काफी ब्रीफ डिस्कस किया था तो
जिसने ने उसको नहीं देखा है जिसको नहीं
पता है तो प्लीज वो उसको समझ सकता है जस्ट
डे 21 की क्लास में हमने उसको सीखा था तो
मशीन हमारी एक्टिव है उस पर तीन सर्विसेस
रन कर रही है तो मैं एक बार आपको फिर से
दिखा देता हूं यह रहा एफटीपी एन नहीं
चाहिए हमें सर्स सजन डिटेक्शन न देन
शिवी तब तक हमारा बब स्वीट ऑन होगा ये रहा
दिस इज आवर बब स्वीट इसको हम क्या कर लेते
हैं अभी स्टार्ट कर लेते हैं
क्योंकि जहां पर हमने लास्ट सेशन को स्टॉप
किया
था यह रहा दे थ्री सर्विसेस आर अवेलेबल
पोर्ट नंबर 21 पोर्ट नंबर 22 पोर्ट नंबर
80 एफटीपी एसएसएस और एचटीटीपी हमने यह चेक
किया था कि जो एफटीपी सर्वर है वह मिस
कॉन्फिन है एनोनिमस लॉगिन के लिए एफटीपी
एनन टी से एसस के लिए हमारे पास कोई भी
क्रेड नहीं है इसलिए एसस के थ्रू हमने कुछ
भी अभी तक इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग नहीं की है
और बात रही हमारी किसकी पोर्ट 80 की तो
अभी हम पोर्ट 80 पर थे तो सबसे पहले हम
चेक करते हैं देखो दिस इ आवर पोर्ट 80 तो
कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व नाउ दिस इज आवर पोर्ट
पोर्ट ए और पोर्ट एटी पर हमें जो
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली थी यह थी डियर एजेंट यूज
योर ओन कोड नेम एज ए यूजर एजेंट टू एक्सेस
द साइट ओके तो यहां पर यह बोल रहा है कि
जो आपका यूजर एजेंट होता है हेडर के अंदर
जो आपका ब्राउजर रिक्वेस्ट करता है सर्वर
को एचटीटीपी हेडर होता उसमें एक यूजर
एजेंट है वहां पर आपको कोड नेम यूज करना
है इस वेबसाइट को एक्सेस करने के लिए बट
हमारे पास कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है कोड
नेम की कि कौन सा कोड नेम यूज करना है तो
उसके लिए हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा अभी बीच
में प्रॉक्सी को यूज करना पड़ेगा और
प्रोक्सी हम कौन सा यूज करने वाले हैं
बर्ब सूट तो एक ब इसको हम कंफिल कर लेते
हैं दिस इ बर्ब सूट और दि टारगेट प्रॉक्सी
इंटरसेप्ट इज ऑन सभी करेंगे पहले ये रहा
फक्सी प्रोक्सी बब स्वीट ऑन बब स्वीट हमने
ऑन कर दिया देन दिस इज आवर बब स्वीट एंड
इसके बाद अब इसम हम क्या कर सकते हैं बार
चेक करते हैं कि व्यू ऑप्शन ओके इसको हम
जूम कर सकते हैं क्या एक
बार इसको हम कहीं पर कहीं से भी जूम नहीं
कर सकते तो मैं एक बार देखता हूं
ओके इसको अभी हम जूम नहीं कर पाएंगे इसकी
सेटिंग अगर हम चेक करेंगे तो नो इट्स ओके
वर नॉट एबल टू जूम इट किसी को पता क्या
शॉर्टकट इसको जूम नहीं कर सकते शायद हम
नहीं कर
पाएंगे बब सेटिंग में जाकर कैसे करेंगे यह
देखा नहीं नहीं कर पाएंगे इसमें ये देखो
यहां पर कोई भी ऐसा ऑप्शन नहीं है कि
जिससे हम क्या कर सकते इसको एक मिनट यूजर
सेटिंग नहीं मैं भी हम टाइम वेस्ट नहीं
करेंगे ओके तो अभी हम क्या करते हैं
सक्सेसफुली हमने प्रॉक्सी सेटअप कर लिया
है लास्ट क्लास में मैंने आपको बताया था
कि प्रोक्सी को कैसे सेटअप करना है
इंस्टॉल करना है कैसे कन्फर करना है तो
अभी हम सिंपली क्या कर रहे हैं इंटरसेप्ट
ऑन करते हैं देन दिस गो टू आवर ब्राउजर और
इसको हम क्या करते हैं
अभी दिस इज आवर इंटरसेप्ट ऑन एंड इसको हम
क्या करते हैं
बार यह रहा और उसके अलावा फिर गो टू बब
स्वीट नाउ इंटरसेप्ट इज ऑन और अभी एक काम
कर देते हैं अरे यार रुको अभी ऑन
करेंगे यह रहा ओके इसको भी हम छोटा कर
लेते हैं ताकि एक स्क्रीन पर दिखाई दे जाए
तो अभी इंटरसेप्ट इज
ऑन इसको हम क्या करते हैं रीस्टार्ट अभी
देखो रिक्वेस्ट हमने कैप्चर कर ली और अभी
आप देखोगे यहां पर यह आपका रिक्वेस्ट है
ये आपकी रिक्वेस्ट है गेट रिक्वेस्ट है ये
एटीटीपी का वर्जन है 1.1 यूज किया जा रहा
है दिस इज योर होस्ट दिस इज योर होस्ट
10.10.1
64214 दिस इज योर यूजर एजेंट जिसकी हम बात
कर रहे थे यूजर एजेंट में क्या इंफॉर्मेशन
है
एप्ट देखने को मिल रहा है एप्ट में क्या
होता है कि
आपको कि जो आपकी वेबसाइट है वह कौन सी
प्रोग्रामिंग लैंग्वेज या स्ट्रक्चर
लैंग्वेज को एक्सेप्ट करेगी तो टेक्स्ट
एचटीएमएल एप्लीकेशन एक्सटीएल यह सारी की
सारी सपोर्ट करेगी देन एप्ट लैंग्वेज
इंग्लिश ओके एप्ट इनकोडिंग मतलब जब भी
क्या करते हैं कि जब भी ब्राउजर से
कम्युनिकेट किया जाता है जब भी डाटा
ट्रांसफर होता है तो उसको इनकोड किया जाता
है तो कौन सा इनकोडिंग यहां पर सपोर्ट
करते हैं जी जिप और डी फलेट ये है उसके
बाद कनेक्शन और यह बाकी क्या है कि यह जो
इंफॉर्मेशन है अभी के लिए आपको इससे कुछ
लेना देना नहीं है हमारी इस सीटीएफ से बस
हमें किससे मतलब है यूजर एजेंट से क्यों
ना हम एक काम करते हैं कि हमारे पास क्या
है यह हमारा यूज योर कोड नेम एज ए यूजर
एजेंट टू एक्सेस द साइट य एजेंट आर अब
यहां पर एक हिंट है कि आर हम इस क्यों ना
आर ट्राई करते हैं इधर और देखते हैं कि
हमें क्या रिजल्ट मिलता है तो अभी हम क्या
करते हैं इसको मॉडिफाई करते हैं मॉडिफाई
करने के लिए सिंपली शिफ्ट और
हमने कर दिया और अब इस रिक्वेस्ट को हम
क्या करते हैं फॉरवर्ड करते हैं रिक्वेस्ट
को क्या करते हम यहां पर क्या है फॉरवर्ड
ओनली फॉरवर्ड करते हैं देखिए अभी इस
रिक्वेस्ट को क्या करते हैं फॉरवर्ड यह
रहा अभी देखिए जैसे हमने रिक्वेस्ट को
फॉरवर्ड किया यह इसका रिस्पांस है
देखो व्हाट आर यू डूइंग आर यू वन ऑफ द 25
एंप्लॉई इफ नॉट आई एम गोइंग टू रिपोर्ट
दिस इंसीडेंट डियर एजेंट यूज योर ओन को
नेम एज यूजर एजेंट टू एक्सेस द साइट फ्रॉम
एजेंट आर अभी अगर आपने नोटिस किया होगा कि
क्या हो सकता है यह यह ऐसी लैंग्वेज अभी
आपने आर यूज किया बट व्ट इ दिस क्या है
यह आपको ऐसा नहीं लग रहा कि वार्निंग
है कि अगर आप अभी यहां पर दो पॉसिबिलिटी
है जो हमने आर यूज किया ठीक है तो आ भी
इसका पार्ट है ओके बट जो एक्सपेक्टेशन है
सीटीएफ की वह और कोई कोड नेम है दूसरा
क्या हमें ठीक है यहां पर एक वार्निंग
मिली हमें एज आर एजेंट बट हम हमें यहां पर
दो तीन चीजें क्लियर होगी एक तो देखो क्या
है कि पहली 25 एंप्लॉई मतलब यहां पर क्या
है इसके अंदर 25 एंप्लॉई है दूसरा कोड नेम
क्या है अल्फाबेट में है कोड नेम क्या है
अल्फाबेट में हमने आ ट्राई किया था बट कोड
नेम क्या आपका अल्फाबेट में है तो इससे अब
हम क्या कर सकते हैं हम क्या कर सकते
बताइए वन बाय वन हम क्या
करेंगे ए बी सी डी हम रख के दे क्योंकि
अल्फाबेट में है देर 26 अल्फाबेट होते हैं
ए से लेकर जड तक 26 अल्फाबेट है तो हमें
क्या करना पड़ेगा वन बाय वन वन बाय वन हम
क्या करेंगे एक एक अल्फाबेट ट्राई करेंगे
जैसे मैंने क्या किया फिर से हम इसको क्या
करते हैं अभी इंटरसेप्ट ऑन है यह रहा फिर
से किया और दिस इज आवर एचटीटीपी रिक्वेस्ट
एक बार इसको फॉरवर्ड करते हैं ये रहा और
एक बार फिर से मैं काम करता ऑफ ऑन देन
उसके बाद फिर से मैं क्या करता हूं एक बार
ऑन यह रहा गेट रिक्वेस्ट और अभी मैं क्या
करता हूं यह रहा यहां पर अ यूज करेंगे हम
ए ए यूज किया और इसको फॉरवर्ड कर दिया बट
हमें कुछ भी नहीं मिला आउटपुट में हमें
कुछ भी नहीं मिला बट एक चीज देखिए वैसे तो
हमें 26 टाइम्स ट्राई करना है बट इट इज
टाइम वेस्ट क्योंकि हम यहां पर क्या कर
रहे हैं अपना टाइम वेस्ट कर रहे हैं अब
टाइम वेस्ट क्योंकि टाइम इज वेरी प्रेशियस
इन केस ऑफ पेन टेस्टिंग तो अभी हमें यहां
पर क्या करना पड़ेगा मैनुअल अप्रोच की
बजाय हम क्या करेंगे यहां पर ब्रूट फोर्स
करेंगे किस किसके द्वारा हम ब्रब सूट के
अंदर ही एक ऑप्शन होता है इंट्रूडर जो
आपको दिखाई दे रहा है इंट्रूडर टैब
इंट्रूडर टैब क्या है ब्रूट फोर्स करने का
काम आता है तो हम इंट्रोड टैब मॉड्यूल की
हेल्प से क्या कर सकते हैं
बब सूट के
द्वारा बलट फोर्स कर सकते हैं ओके तो कैसे
कर सकते हैं देखिए अभी मैं फिर से
इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ फिर से इंटरसेप्ट
ऑन यह रहा रिक्वेस्ट देन उसके बाद एक मिनट
ऑफ ऑन य रहा दिस वन यह रहा इंटरसेप्ट इ ऑन
यहां पर राइट क्लिक सेंड टू इंट्रूडर जैसे
इंट्रूडर में सेंड किया गो टू योर
इंट्रूडर अब इंट्रूडर में आप क्या कर सकते
हो देखो अभी हम अटक कर रहे य पर ट्राई
करेंगे तो अभी हम यहां पर क्या करेंगे यह
रहा यहां पर ये रहा यूजर एजेंट को हम
सेलेक्ट करेंगे यूजर एजेंट को हम क्या
करेंगे सेलेक्ट करेंगे यह रहा य हाईलाइट
करना है देन उसके बाद ऐड डॉलर जैसे हम
इसको क्या किया तो यहां पर क्या करेंगे हम
ऐड कर सकते हैं अभी यहां पर हमें क्या
करना पड़ेगा पेलोड ऐड करना पड़ेगा पेलोड
मतलब वर्ड लिस्ट चाहिए अभी क्या मुझे एक
चीज बताइए वर्ड लिस्ट में ऐसे करूंगा देखि
ए
फिर से ए
ऐड बी ऐड ये तो सेम बात होगी कि मैं यह
सारे एकएक ट्राई तो हम खुद से भी ट्राई कर
सकते हैं तो अभी मुझे क्या करना पड़ेगा
वर्ड लिस्ट को क्रिएट करना होगा हमें क्या
करना होगा वर्ड लिस्ट को क्रिएट करना होगा
अभी यहां पर मुझे यह बताइए कि वर्ड लिस्ट
को क्रिएट करने के लिए क्या मुझे कोई
पाइथन की स्क्रिप्ट लिखनी पड़ेगी या कोई
ऐसा टूल्स अवेलेबल है जिसकी हेल्प से मैं
वर्ड लिस्ट कस्टम वर्ड लिस्ट क्रिएट कर
सकता हूं या जनरेट कर सकता हूं
कोई जानता है किसी को पता है कि कोई टूल
हम यहां पर यूज कर सकते हैं क् यहां पर
टाइम कंजूमिंग है अभी हम कस्टम वर्ड लिस्ट
क्रिएट करनी है हमें पता है कि दे 26
अल्फाबेट्स कैपिटल अल्फाबेट्स है तो मुझे
एक वर्ड लिस्ट क्रिएट करनी है क्या मैं
खुद की स्क्रिप्ट लिखूंगा कोई पाइथन की या
बेस स्क्रिप्ट कोई या मैं कोई टूल का यूज
कर सकता हूं कोई टूल अवेलेबल है फ्रीली
टूल अवेलेबल है बताइए
बताइए बताइए बताइए सभी लोग जवाब
दीजिए नहीं नहीं कुमावत नहीं जो क्यूल टूल
होता है यह आपको वेबसाइट वेब पेज को क्रॉल
करके वर्ड लिस्ट क्रिएट करता है बट यह
आपकी कस्टम वर्ड लिस्ट क्रिएट नहीं करेगा
जैसी आपको
चाहिए बताइए और कोई हमारे स्टूडेंट जो
लाइव में है में प्लीज
बताइए किसी को लगता है कि कौन सा टूल हम
यूज कर सकते हैं इसके
लिए यस टेक मिनिस जो आपका नाम है या प्रणय
ने भी सही जवाब दिया शुभम ने भी सही जवाब
दिया है तो हम क्या कर सकते हैं क्रंच
क्रंच एक कस्टम वर्डलिस्ट जनरेटर टूल्स
होता है जो हम यूज कर सकते हैं फॉर
एग्जांपल जो बाय डिफॉल्ट काली के अंदर आता
है तो हम क्या करते हैं अभी मेन
कंच कंच टूल को ओके है या नहीं है नहीं
इसमें हम चेक करते
हैं करं ओके करं हैब इसको हम इसका मेन पेज
ओपन करते
हैं
वेट यह रहा अभ ये क्या है कंच क्या है
जनरेट वर्डलिस्ट फ्रॉम ए कैरेक्टर सेट ठीक
है अब ये देखो कंच कैन क्रिएट ए वर्डलिस्ट
बेस्ड ऑन एरिया यू स्पेसिफाई द आउटपुट
फ्रॉम क्रंच कैन बी सेंट टू द स्क्रीन
फाइल टू और टू अनदर प्रोग्राम द
रिक्वायर्ड पैरामीटर्स आर देखिए मिनिमम
लेंथ मैक्सिमम लेंथ यह आपके हाथ में आप
कुछ भी स्पेसिफाई कर सकते उसके बाद कस्टम
वर्ड जो आपको चाहिए जैसे कि मुझे यह रहा
हान टी के साथ हम यूज कर
रेट कॉमा परसेंटेज सिंबल और एरो अपर एरो
देखो ट द रेट क्या करता है इंसर्ट लो व
केस कैरेक्टर कॉमा विल इंसर्ट अपर केस
कैरेक्टर्स परसेंटेज विल इंसर्ट नंबर्स या
विल इंसर्ट सिंबल्स और भी बहुत सारे
ऑप्शंस है अगर इसको हम यूज करेंगे तो एक
बेहतरीन और एक बहुत ही अच्छी वर्ड लिस्ट
एज पर यर रिक्वायरमेंट आप इस टूल से
क्रिएट कर सकते हो बड़ी से बड़ी वर्ड
लिस्ट छोटी से छोटी वर्ड लिस्ट आप क्रिएट
कर सकते हो अभी मैं क्विट करता हूं इसको
इसके द्वारा हम क्या करते हैं एक वर्ड
लिस्ट क्रिएट करते हैं वर्डलिस्ट क्रिएट
करने के लिए अभ क्या करेंगे हम
क्रंच क्रंच उसके बाद मिनिमम लेंथ क्या वन
है मैक्सिमम लेंथ भी मेरी वन है क्योंकि
हमें चाहिए कैपिटल अल्फाबेट उसके बाद हाइन
t का यूज करेंगे देन उसके बाद कॉमा कॉमा
यूज क्यों किया क्योंकि हमें चाहिए कैपिटल
अल्फाबेट देन यह जनरेट करके हम किसके अंदर
एक फाइल के अंदर सेव करना चाहते हैं फाइल
का नाम हम
रखेंगे
[संगीत]
कि
एजेंट एजेंट डटी एक्सटी एजेंट डटी एक्सटी
ओके और हिट एंटर
देखि नंबर ऑफ लाइन 26 और इट विल जनरेट
इसने सक्सेसफुली जनरेट कर दिया फिर से बता
देता हूं करं मिनिमम लेंथ वन मैक्सिमम
लेंथ वन हाइन टी मतलब हमें स्पेसिफाई करना
कि पैटर्न में किस टाइप के कैरेक्टर चाहिए
कॉमा ऑल अपर केस यह क्या आपका रीडायरेक्शन
ऑपरेटर है यह क्या करे एजेंट्स के अंदर
सेव कर देगा अभी हम कैट करते हैं एजेंट
डटी एक्सटी यह देखिए हिट एंटर ए टू जड
हमने क्या कर दिया य पर क्रिएट कर दिया
अभी इसी चीज को हम क्या करेंगे य पर लोड
कर देंगे क्लियर किया यहां पर हम करें लोड
और लोड हम कहां से करेंगे
अपने वी आर
इनसाइड हम
पीडब्ल्यूडी डाउनलोडस के अंदर ओके हमें
क्या करना पड़ेगा डाउनलोड के अंदर जाना
पड़ेगा तो तो तो यह रहा डाउनलोड और इसके
अंदर हमारे पास होगा एजेंट डटी एक्सटी ये
रहा एेंट डटी एक्सटी सीधा ओपन कर लिया
हमने यहां पर ओपन कर लिया ये रहा 26
कैरेक्टर है देन उसके बाद डायरेक्टली मैं
क्या करूंगा स्टार्ट
अटैक देखिए ओके कम्युनिटी एडिशंस है तो
कुछ लिमिटेशन इसकी बट इट विल स्टार्ट द
अटैक्स क्योंकि दिस इज वेरी बेसिक अटैक्स
बहुत ही छोटा अटैक है इतना छोटा अटैक कहीं
पर भी नहीं
होता और यहां पर हमें देखो कौन सी
इंफॉर्मेशन देखनी है एक तो स्टेटस कोड
दूसरा हमें लेंथ पर ध्यान देना है ओके
देखिए जहां पर क्या है कि डिफरेंट वर्ड
होगा जहां पर कुछ भी
किसी भी पेलोड की वजह से कुछ रिजल्ट
डिफरेंस हुआ होगा वहां पर लेंथ बदल जाएगी
दूसरा स्टेटस कोर बदल जाएगा अरवाज स्टेटस
को लगभग सेम रहेगा तो अभी हम देख सकते हैं
य पर देखिए स्टेटस कोड अलग किसका य हम
चलते नीचे देखिए अभी 302 एक तो यह रहा
नीचे चलते हैं ना ना ओके स्टेटस कोड य एक
तो ए बी सी एक होके नीचे चलते हैं देखो
वैसे आर पर देखोगे एज इट इज है सी सी प
देखो 302 है बाकी 200 है लेंथ देखिए 458
बाकी हम 446 446 देखि लेंथ के बेस पर अगर
क्लिक करेंगे आप देखो 538 किस पर आर पे है
इसमें लेंथ लेंथ का डिफरेंस आया है बाकी
जो सी है उसमें क्या है 458 बाकी में 446
लेंथ है बाकी में सब में 446 लेंथ आपको
देखने को मिलेगी या 445 है तो बेसिकली वी
कैन से ट कि हम ट्राई कर सकते हैं सी को
अभी हम क्या कर सकते हैं ट्राई कर सकते
हैं सी को उसका देखेंगे तोय देखो 302
फाउंड ओके अनाउंसमेंट डियर एजेंट योर ओन
कोड एक्सेस सोन सो ओके अभी हम क्या करते
इसको यूरल में कॉपी करते हैं अपने यूआरएल
में ओपन करते हैं देखते हैं कि क्या
रिजल्ट हमें मिल रहा है देखो हम क्या करते
हैं यहां पर रिक्वेस्ट इन ब्राउजर
इन ओरिजिनल सेशन ओके कॉपी यह रहा हमने
कॉपी किया और यहां परभ हम क्या करते हैं
ये रहा पेस्ट और इसे करने से पहले हम क्या
कर इंटरसेप्ट ऑफ कर देंगे इसमें इंटरसेप्ट
क्या करेंगे ऑफ तब तक के लिए इंटरसेप्ट
क्या करेंगे ऑफ भैया ऑफ हो जाओ
देन यह रहा हिट एंटर अभी यहां पर हम क्या
कर सकते हैं व्ट
हैपन यह रहा यह रहा हमारा रिजल्ट
देखिए कि एजेंट अंडर सी अटेंशन पीएपी
अटेंशन
सी एच आर आई एस क्रिस बोल सकते हैं डू यू
स्टिल रिमेंबर अवर डील प्लीज टेल एजेंट जे
अबाउट द स्टफ एज सून एज पॉसिबल आल्सो चेंज
योर गडम पासवर्ड इज वीक फ्रॉम एजेंट आर
मतलब जो सी था एक राइट आंसर था और उस हमें
पता चल गया कि जो कोड नेम उस वेबसाइट को
एक्सेस करने के लिए चाहिए था वो आपका क्या
था कैपिटल सी था जो अल्फाबेट में था
कैपिटल सी वो कोड नेम था जिससे हमें पता
चल गया कि ये क्या है एक यूजर नेम है एक
सी है मुझे अगर इस वेबसाइट को एक्सेस करना
है अगर या यह जो यूजर है क्रिस अगर इसको
वेबसाइट को एक्सेस करना है तो इसको खुद की
वेबसाइट को एक्सेस करने के लिए अपना कोड
नेम यूज करना पड़ेगा जिसका कोड नेम क्या
है कैपिटल सी और ये इसके अंदर इंफॉर्मेशन
अवेलेबल है और इसका एक और चीज है इसका
मतलब कि यहां पर इसका पासवर्ड एक वीक है
इसका पासवर्ड क्या है वक है तो अभी मुझे
ये बताइए कि यूजर नेम क्रिस है अभी यहां
पर मुझे पासवर्ड फाइंड आउट करना है
और ड्यूरिंग इंफॉर्मेशन गैदरिंग हमारे पास
इंफॉर्मेशन यह है कि हमारे पास तीन
सर्विसेस है एफटीपी एसएसए और एचटीटीपी तो
मुझे यह बताइए कि अभी मैं पासवर्ड कैसे
फाइंड आउट करूंगा ओबवियसली मैं ब्रूट
फोर्स के द्वारा ही करूंगा बट ब्रूट फोर्स
में किस पर ट्राई करूंगा बताइए चैट में
बताइए और कोई ओके हम हाइड्रा का जरूर यूज
करेंगे बट यह मुझे बताइए
कि किस
पर ओके एसएसएस यूज कर सकते हो
बाकी एटी प नहीं कर सकता मैं एचटीटीपी
कौन सी सर्विस का यूज करूंगा मैं एचटीटीपी
एफटीपी
एसएसए सभी लोग एसएसए बोल रहे हैं क्या मैं
एचटीटीपी पे नहीं कर
सकता एटीटीपी पर कैसे
करेंगे लॉगिन फॉर्म कहां है लॉगिन फॉर्म
कहीं पर भी नहीं है एचटीटीपी में यही तो
कारण है यही आपकी कॉमन सेंस काम आती है कि
आप क्या सोच रहे हो क्या नहीं सोच रहे ओके
यही मैं जानना चाह रहा हूं कि अभी एक चीज
बताइए आप कि अगर तीन सर्विस अवेलेबल है
जहां पर एफटीपी एसएसएस और एचटीटीपी
एचटीटीपी प हमने अभी हाल ही में एमेशन
परफॉर्म किया है जहां पर हमने ब्रूट फोर्स
ट्राई किया ब्रूट फोर्स की वजह से हमने एक
पेज फाइंड आउट किया उस पेज में हमें एक
इंफॉर्मेशन मिली यूजर जिसका कौन सा है यह
रहा यह इंफॉर्मेशन मिली है जिसका कोड नेम
सी है कहीं पर भी आपको लॉगिन फॉर्म देखने
को मिला कहीं पर
भी नहीं आवाज कम नहीं है
यार बताइए कहीं पर भी आपको एचटीटीपी में
लॉगिन फॉर्म देखने को
मिला तो हम एचटीटीपी पर ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई
नहीं कर सकते हम क्या करेंगे एफटीपी या
एसस कोई भी कर सकते हैं तो अभी हम सबसे
पहले क्या करते हैं एफटीपी करते हैं विद द
हेल्प ऑफ हाइड्रा ओके तो सबसे पहले हम
क्या करेंगे हाइड्रा उसके बाद
हाइन स्मल एल उसके बाद यह रहा यूजर नेम
क्योंकि यज हमारे पास है कॉपी
[संगीत]
एंड कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व देन उसके बाद हमारे
पास पासवर्ड ले कैपिटल प देन रो कड एकटी
हो सकती है एक मिनट हमारे पास पास फर्स्ट
ऑफ ल वी शुड चेक वे आवर रोक एक्सटी फाइल
इज अवेलेबल एल एस एंड ओके इ देर एनी रोक
डटी एकस य नो नो नो नो
[संगीत]
नो लास्ट टाइम हमने कहां पर सेव किया था व
हमें देखना
पड़ेगा ओके ओके ओके ओके सीडी
ओके वर्ड लिस्ट सीडी वर्ड
लिस्ट यह रहा रोक डटी एक्सटी हमारी वर्ड
लिस्ट है तो अभी हम क्या करेंगे हमारे
पीडब्लूडी प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी
हमारी क्या है पीडब्लूडी
कॉपी य
पर पेस्ट उसके बाद हम क्या करेंगे य पर
प्र कड
एक्सटी रोक डटी एक्सटी देन उसके बाद हमारा
टारगेट रहेगा व्ट इ द इ
विट ओके रोटी एक्सटी देन हमारे पास टारगेट
आईपी
एड्रेस च इज आवर टारगेट आईपी एड्रेस इ ट
ये रहा ये अपना टारगेट आईपी है
कंट्रोल ये रहा टारगेट आईपी और यह रहा
पेस्ट देन उसके बाद हमें मेंशन करना
पड़ेगा कौन सी सर्विस हम यूज कर रहे
हैं एफटीपी पर कर रहे हम एफटीपी ओके और
सिंपली हिट एंटर क्योंकि हम पहली बार यूज
नहीं कर रहे हैं हाइड्रा को हाइड्रा को
आपने पिछली क्लास में भी यूज किया
है डायरेक्टरी एमेशन हमने परफॉर्म किया था
उसमें हमें कुछ भी नहीं मिला था डर बस्टर
के द्वारा सबको अगर किसी को याद होगा तो
लास्ट क्लास में हमने परफॉर्म किया था बट
वी डिड नॉट फाइंड
नथिंग गो बस्ट आप यूज कर सकते हो या डर
बस्टर का यूज कर सकते हो बट बात वही आती
है कि उसके थ्रू हमें य पेज मोर कोई
इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली जो इंफॉर्मेशन अभी
मैंने आपको दिखा दिया विद द हेल्प ऑफ बब
स्वीट बस वो लास्ट
थी इसमें इट विल टेक टाइम बाकी इसके अलावा
भी हम क्या कर सकते
हैं अभी हम ब्रूट फोर्स कर रहे विद द
हेल्प ऑफ हाइड्रा एफटीपी के ऊपर इसके
अलावा और क्या कर सकते हैं किसी के मन में
और कोई आईडिया हो जो हम कर सकते हैं
परफॉर्म कर सकते
हैं बताइए यह रहा अभी हमें पासवर्ड मिल
गया देखिए व
सक्सेसफुली परफॉर्म द ब्रूट फोर्स ओके क
दिस क्रिस्टल इज पासवर्ड तो हमें क्या
करते हैं अभी एफटीपी लॉग इन करते हैं
एफटीपी कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व देन उसके बाद हिट
एंटर
और सी एच आर आई एस क्रिस ओके पासवर्ड क्या
है क्रिस्टल सी आर
वाई क्रिस्टल हिट एंटर नाउ वी सक्सेसफुली
लॉग इन इन टू द एफटीपी अभी हम चेक करते
हैं कि एफटीपी के अंदर क्याक है क्योंकि
यह रहा तो एफटीपी के अंदर हमारे पास तीन
फाइल है टू एजेंट जड एक्
क्यूट एलियन जेपीजी कटीड पीएनजी वाओ वेरी
गुड तो इनको हम क्या कर लेते हैं अभी अपनी
मशीन पर डाउनलोड कर लेते हैं का पर
डाउनलोड के अंदर तो डाउनलोड के अंदर गेट
उसके
बाद टू एजेंट टी एक्स हिट एंटर ओके देन
सेकंड फाइल है क्यूट यह रहा क्यूट
एलियन एलियन ड जेपीजी
देन उसके बाद
गेट उसके बाद है हमारे पास नेक्स्ट
क्यूटी डॉट पीएनजी तो हमें तीन फाइल मिली
एफटीपी सर्वर के ऊपर व तीनों तीनों फाइल
हमने क्या कर ली अपने लोकल मशीन के ऊपर
डाउनलोड कर लिया तो अभी इसको हम बाय बोल
देते हैं क्योंकि इससे हमारा काम हो गया
तो एलस करते हैं तो हमने तीन फाइल यहां पर
डाउनलोड की होंगी एक तो क्यूटी एलियन
जेपीजी और दूसरा यह क्यूटी पीएनजी और हमें
मिली होगी तो अभी हम इसको एक काम करते हैं
एम केडी आई
आर मेक डायरेक्टरी एक है लैब फर के नाम से
बनाते हैं और इन फाइल को हम क्या करेंगे
ट्रांसफर कर देते हैं तो मू एक फाइल थी
टू टू एजेंट
टू एजेंट एक और कौन सी
ओके किसके अंदर
नेक्स्ट अपनी है लब
फोर लेफ फोर के अंदर हमने इसको मूव कर
दिया एक और फाइल को मूव कर देते हैं कौन
सी पीएनजी को ले फोर के अंदर इट एंटर
देन
मूव यहा तो मूव अभी सीडी करते हैं लेफ
फ यह रहा तो यह तीन फाइल हमें मिली थी तो
सबसे पहले हम टी एक्सटी फाइल को रीड करते
टी एक्सटी फाइल हमें क्या मिलता
है यह रहा तो टी एकटी फाइल में हमें मिलता
है यह रहा डियर एजेंट जे डियर एजेंट
जे ऑल दीज एलियन लाइक फोटोज आर
फेक एजेंट आर स्टोर्ड द जो एजेंट आर स्टोर
द रियल पिक्चर इनसाइड योर डायरेक्टरी योर
लॉगिन पासवर्ड इज सम हाउ स्टोर्ड इन द फेक
पिक्चर इट शुड नॉट बी ए प्रॉब्लम फॉर यू
फ्रॉम एजेंट सी वा अभी एक काम करते हैं हम
यह ओपन करते हैं ऐसा क्या है इन फाइल्स
में जो हमें देखना पड़ेगा देखो डाउनलोड
ओपन
फोल्डर और इसके अंदर हम ओपन करते हैं लैब
फोर यह ओके यह दो फाइल है कटीड पीएनजी और
पीएनजी ओके यह दो फाइल है इट्स ओके नाउ
इसने बोला है
कि कि जो आपको यह एलियन जैसी फोटो दिखाई
दे रही है य फेक है जो असली फोटो है रियल
पिक्चर्स है व आपके एजेंट आर के
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर है अगर आपको क्या करना
है लॉग इन करना है कैसे ना कैसे तो आपको
क्या करना पड़ेगा यर पासवर्ड स्टोर्ड इन द
फेक पिक्चर्स इट शुड नॉट बी अ प्रॉब्लम
फॉर यू तो यह जो टेक्स्ट है इस टेक्स्ट को
पढ़ के आपको कुछ समझ आ रहा है कि आपको
क्या लग रहा है कि टेक्स्ट आपको क्या हिंट
दे रहा है
बताइए यस वेरी गुड
शुभम हमें यहां पर स्टैग एनालिसिस करना
पड़ेगा क्योंकि यहां पर जो यूजर्स है या
जिसकी य लैब है या जिसने भी इसको बनाया है
उसने क्या यहां पर टेगो ग्राफी का यूज
किया है इंफॉर्मेशन हाइड करने के लिए
लेकिन वी आर अटैकर्स और हमें क्या करना है
स्टैक एनालिसिस का यूज करना है ओके स्टैग
एनालिसिस का यूज करना है एलियन में
पासवर्ड है वी कैन से दैट ये नहीं कह सकते
हम इने बोला फोटोज फोटोज मतलब इन फोटो में
हमें क्या करनी पड़ेगी स्टैग एनालिसिस
करनी पड़ेगी और सबको पता है कि अगर मुझे
स्टैग एनालिसिस करनी है तो मुझे जल्दी से
यह बताइए कि जब हमने स्टैग एनालिसिस डे 21
नहीं डे 20 में पढ़ा था तो मुझे यह बताइए
कि मैंने आपको बताया था कि स्टैग एनालिसिस
करने के लिए कुछ स्टेप्स फॉलो करते हैं
कितने स्टेप्स फॉलो करते हैं हम बताना
सीरीज में
बताना स्टैग एनालिसिस के लिए हम कितने
स्टेप फॉलो करते हैं और कैसे कैसे करते
हैं और सेम स्टेप यहीं पर फॉलो करेंगे हम
बताइए मैं सभी स्टूडेंट से आंसर चाहता
हूं बताइए आपको काफी हेल्प
मिलेगी यह सारी चीजें सॉल्व करने में और
शायद मुझे पता चल गया कि आप लोग धीरे-धीरे
सीख रहे हो बहुत कुछ आपके पास एक अप्रोच
हो गई है पेन टेस्टिंग की
फर्स्ट एजिप टूल ओके कितने स्टेप्स
प्रोसेस है कितने स्टेप्स की प्रोसेस है
मुझे
बताइए ओके तीन ओके
मतलब यस टू फोर बोल सकते हो ओके वेरी गुड
चलो सबसे पहले हम क्या करेंगे अभी एजिप
टूल का यूज करेंगे तो हम एजिप टूल सबसे हम
कौन सी फाइल पर करते हैं हम सबसे पहले
जेपीजी पर करते हैं चलो ओके तो जेपीजी पर
हम करेंगे एजि
टूल एजिप टूल उसके बाद
क्यूटी एलियन ड जेपीजी और हिट
एंटर क्या मुझे बताइए इस इंफॉर्मेशन को
देख के आपको कुछ लग रहा है कि कुछ आपके
लिए यूजफुल इंफॉर्मेशन है कुछ आपके काम की
इंफॉर्मेशन है देखिए 13 कटी जो सोन सो दिस
वन दिस वन परमिशन जेपीजी जेपीजी इमेज ये
इंज कुछ आपको इस इंफॉर्मेशन को देख के बता
सकते हो कि कुछ आपके लिए यूजफुल
इंफॉर्मेशन है आपके कुछ काम की
हो मतलब यहां पर आपके काम की इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं है तो वी आर नॉट श्यर कि इंफॉर्मेशन
हम इससे गेट कर पा रहे नहीं कर पा रहे तो
नेक्स्ट टूल हम यूज करेंगे इसके ऊपर
बिनवाक फिर से हम क्या करेंगे बिन वक बिन
वक उसके
बाद
ड्यूटी
हाइन ओके यह रहा नेक्स्ट हिट
एंटर ओके जो बिनवाक टूल हमारा यह भी हमें
क्या है यह बता रहा है कि ओके जीरो जीरो
इसके अंदर कुछ भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं है तो
अगेन हम बिन वक टूल की हेल्प से भी हमें
कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिल रही तो
नेक्स्ट स्टेप हम कौन सा परफॉर्म करेंगे
नेक्स्ट टूल हम कौन सा यूज करेंगे
बताइए
बताइए जल्दी से नेक्स्ट टूल हम कौन सा यूज
करने वाले
हैं किसी को पता है हमने दो स्टेप पूरे कर
लिए कि लेकिन अभी तक हमें दो स्टेप में
कोई भी इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं मिली रिलेटेड टू
आवर
इमेज यस स्टैग हाइट हम यूज करने वाले हैं
तो स्टैग
हाइट उसके बाद एक्सट्रैक्ट यह रहा देन
उसके बाद यह रहा एक्सट्रैक्ट हाइन एफ उसके
बाद हम यूज
करेंगे क्यूटी
हाइफ एलियन ड पीएनजी और हिट एंटर वाओ एंटर
पास फ्रेज
अगेन जैसे हम पिछली बार फंसे थे अब कीी
बार यह बोल रहा है कि मुझे पासवर्ड चाहिए
मतलब इस इमेज के अंदर कुछ ऐसी चीज छुपा
रखी है जिसके जो क्या है पासवर्ड
प्रोटेक्टेड है अब हमारे पास पासवर्ड तो
है नहीं लेकिन वी आर श्यर कि इसके अंदर
डाटा है नेक्स्ट हमें क्या करना होगा
बताइए अभी हमारे पास पासवर्ड नहीं
है स्ट्रिंग्स कमांड का आप यूज कर सकते हो
ओके वेरी गुड मैं आपको दिखा देता हूं
स्ट्रिंग्स कमांड का भी हम यूज कर सकते
हैं कोई इशू नहीं है इमेज के अंदर लेकिन
यह इमेज है इमेज में स्ट्रिंग्स कमांड में
आपको क्या मिलेगा बताइए ये रहा हिट एंटर
देखो
स्ट्रिंग कमांड में बताइए आपको क्या देख
को लग रहा है कि कोई क्या इंफॉर्मेशन है
देखो
यह यह पासवर्ड प्रोटेक्टेड है तो आपको
स्ट्रिंग कमांड तो वैसे कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन
नहीं दे पाएगी
ओके तो मतलब इससे भी हमें कुछ पता नहीं चल
रहा है वेरी गुड कि आपको पता है स्ट्रिंग
कमांड का भी हम यूज करते हैं ओके तो अभी
हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा नेक्स्ट टूल ब्रूट
फोर्स करना पड़ेगा
पासवर्ड को ब्रेक करना
पड़ेगा तो पासवर्ड ब्रेक करने के लिए हम
कौन सा टूल यूज करेंगे इसके
लिए अच्छा जी जोन का यूज करोगे और कोई टूल
नहीं
है वाओ कितना अच्छा जवाब दिया है बब सूट
तो यह टास्क है आप आप बब सूट से करके
दिखाइए इसका
पासवर्ड अगर आप कर पाओ
तो इमेज जब स्टैगो ग्राफी के ज स्टग हाइड
वाले पासवर्ड है उनको क्रैक करने के लिए
हमें स्टैग सिक नाम के टूल का यूज करते
हैं कौन सा
स्टैग सिक अभी स्टैग सिक ओके स्टैक सिक
टूल का यूज करते हैं हम और स्टैक सिक देन
उसके बाद फाइल का नाम अ टैग सिक क्या आपका
वर्ल्ड फास्टेस्ट टैग हाइड क्रैकर होता है
और स्टैग हाइड क्रैकर क्या होता है जब भी
हम क्या करते हैं किसी भी इमेज का
एनालिसिस करते हैं ठीक है और उस इमेज के
अंदर कुछ इंफॉर्मेशन हाइड की गई है अगर
आपके पास उस इमेज का अगर वो पासवर्ड
प्रोटेक्टेड है अगर उसके पास आपके पास
उसका पासवर्ड है तो आप स्टैग हाइड टूल की
हेल्प से ओपन करके उस इमेज के अंदर की
इंफॉर्मेशन फाइंड आउट कर सकते हो अगर आपके
पास उस इमेज का पासवर्ड नहीं है आपको
पासवर्ड करना है तो पासवर्ड क्रैक करने के
लिए आपको क्या करना पड़ेगा इस टूल का यूज
करना पड़गा सच में दिस वेरी वेरी फास्ट
टूल अभी देख लेना फिर से स्टक सिक देन
उसके बाद
क्यूट एलियन डॉट उसके बाद हम वर्ड लिस्ट
मेंशन करेंगे कौन सी वर्ड लिस्ट देखिए एक
तो होम डायरेक्टरी के
अंदर वर्ड लिस्ट वर्ड लिस्ट के अंदर रोटी
एक्सटी अभी हम इसको दे रहे डटी एक्सटी और
हिट एंटर
ना और देखिए इतना फास्ट हैय फाउंड पासवर्ड
एरिया 51 एरिया 51 इसके अंदर क्या है फाइल
नेम मैसेज डटी एक्सटी और यहां पर एक्सट
करके रख दिया ओके अभ एलस करते हैं आपको य
फाइल देखने को मिलेगी क्यूट एलियन जपजी आट
ओके तो अभी हम इसको क्या करते कैट करते
हैं क्यूट एलिड जपजी आट ट एंटर अ हाय
जेम्स
ग्लैड यू फाइंड दिस मैसेज योर लॉगइन
पासवर्ड इज हैकर रूल्स एस्केलेशन मार्क्स
डोंट आस्क मी व्हाई द पासवर्ड लुक चीजी
आस्क एजेंट आर हु सेट दिस पासवर्ड फॉर यू
योर बडी क्रिस मतलब यूजर नेम क्या आपका
आपका यूजर नेम आपका जेम्स उसका पासवर्ड
क्या आपका हैकर रूल्स ये रहा और ओके इसको
हम क्या करते हैं अभी एफटीपी ट्राई करते
हैं चलो ओके
एफटीपी कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व हिट
एंटर रघु बिना वर्ड लिस्ट दिए कैसे क्रैक
करेगा बताइए यार थोड़ा सा जवाब तो ऐसा
दीजिए कि मतलब जो सवाल तो ऐसा पूछिए कि जो
आप कुछ तो लॉजिक होना चाहिए ना आपके सवाल
में सब बिना वर्ड लिस्ट के कर
देगा ओके हिट एंटर हमारा
यूजर नेम है
जेम्स जेम्स हिट एंटर पासवर्ड हमारा य रहा
हैकर
रूल्स हैकर रूल्स हिट
एंटर लॉग इन फील्ड मतलब यह एफटीपी के
क्रेडेंशियल नहीं हो सकते अब क्या करेंगे
हम ऐसे ट्राई
करेंगे तो एक काम होता है रघु आप के में
ऐसा इसलिए हुआ क्योंकि कोई भी टूल्स होता
है खास कर के जो ब्रूट फोर्सर टूल्स होते
हैं वो बाय डिफॉल्ट एक वर्ड लिस्ट का भी
यूज करते हैं खुद की बाय डिफॉल्ट
वर्डलिस्ट विदाउट वर्डलिस्ट वो क्रैक नहीं
करते हर एक जैसे जोन द रिपर टूल भी होता
है उसकी भी एक डिफॉल्ट वर्ड लिस्ट होती है
जो अगर आप मेंशन नहीं करते उसको वह लेता
ही लेता है ऐसे हर एक टूल्स की अपनी एक
बाय डिफॉल्ट वर्डलिस्ट होती है मैक्सिमम
टूल्स की जिसको वो उससे कंपैरिजन करके अगर
वहां पर वैल्यू है तो आपको मिल जाता है
सीटी के केस में मिल जाती है रियल
सिनेरियो में नॉट पॉसिबल तो ओके तो अभी हम
एसएसएस ट्राई करते हैं
एसएसए जेम्स
रेट अभी हम क्या करते हैं यह
रहा
कॉपी पेस्ट क्लिप बोर्ड वाओ ट व्ट इ द इशू
यार
रेट देन उसके बाद हिट
एंटर अभी यहां पर हमें क्या करना है
पासवर्ड मेंशन करना
होगा
यस उसके बाद हम क्या करने वाले
हैं हिट
एंटर नाउ वी सक्सेसफुली लॉगिन इन टू द
मशीन हमें क्या हो गया जो जेम्स यूजर है
उसके थ्रू हमें सर्वर का एक्सेस मिल गया
एजेंट सर्वर का देखिए य रहा अभी मैं
पीडब्ल्यूडी करूंगा प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायक
मेरी क्या है होम जेनस और एलस करता हूं तो
एलस करने पर मुझे क्या मिला एक तो एलियन
ऑस्पा जपजी और यूजर फ्लग डटी एक्टी यूजर
फ्लग डटी एक्टी मैं इसको क्या करता हूं तो
यूजर फ्लैग अंडर डटी एक्टी हिट एंटर तो
हमें एक फ्लैग तो मिल गया ये रहा तो अब
इसको हम क्या करते
कॉपी करते सबमिट कर देते हैं चलो एक चीज
तो हमें मिल गई है अभी इसके थोड़े आंसर
करते हैं यह रहा कैपचरिंग द यूजर फ्लैग
ओके ऑलरेडी मैं सबमिट कर चुका
हूं नाउ उसके बाद प्र एलेशन करेंगे ओके
नाउ नाउ ओके ट फ्लैग है तो आंसर हम बाद
में कर लेंगे इसके क्वेश्चन को तो एक काम
करते अभी कंटिन्यू करते हैं क्रैकिंग तो
इसको हम सबमिट करवा चुके हैं अभी मुझे य
बताइए दूसरी इमेज थी चलो हम दूसरी इमेज को
भी क्या कर सकते
हैं कि हम दूसरी इमेज को क्या कर सकते
हैं ट्राई करते हैं तो एक बार इसको हम
क्या करते हैं एग्जिट करते हैं एग्जिट कर
सकते हैं तो नया वेब ओपन करते हैं पेज दिस
इज अवर न्यू पेज एंड सीडी लब
फर ओके
डाउनलोड्स लेफ फॉर एलस ना अभी स्टस करते
दूसरी इमेज का भी करें स्टार्ट
करें स्टार्ट
करें सेकंड इमेज का भी स्टक स्टार्ट करें
हम
बताइए ओके तो सबसे पहले हम क्या करेंगे
एजिप टूल का यूज करेंगे फिर से और अभी हम
फाइल कौन सी यूज करने है
पीएनजी कौन सी
फाइल
क्यूटी डॉट पीएनजी हिट एंटर देखिए कुछ
सस्पिशंस
लग रहा है किसी को पढ़ो ध्यान
से बिल्कुल ध्यान से पढ़ो कुछ भी सस्पिशंस
पीश
ध्यान से पढ़ो बिल्कुल आपको क्या लग रहा
है कि फाइल में कुछ
सस्पिशंस तो क्या है स
नहीं चंक वार्निंग और कुछ
सस्पिशंस
देखिए थोड़ा आपको मिल रहा है कि इसके अंदर
कुछ बाइनरी डाटा 762 बाइट यूज हाइन बी
ऑप्शन टू एक्सट्रैक्ट बाइनरी डाटा 42 वाइट
यूज हाइन बी ऑप्शन टू एक्सट्रैक्ट मतलब
इसके अंदर कोई बाइनरी डाटा है यह आपको एक
हिंट है अगर हमें कोई भी बाइनरी डाटा का
हिंट मिलता है तो सबसे बेस्ट टूल हमारे
पास क्या है बाइनरी एनालाइजर जिसका नाम
क्या है बिन वक जो फर्मवेयर एनालाइजर है
तो हम क्या करेंगे बिन वक टूल का यूज
करेंगे और इसके ऊपर हम क्या करते हैं अभी
परफॉर्म करते हैं ना ओ यह रहा बिन
वक कटी
डॉट ओके डॉट पीएनजी हिट एंटर
य
देखो नाउ अबकी बार हमें रिजल्ट मिल रहा है
क्योंकि देखो पासवर्ड होगा देखि कंप्रेस
डाटा बेस्ट कंप्रेशन ओके जिप आर्काइव डाटा
इनक्रिप्टेड कंप्रेस साइज 98 अनकंप्रेस
साइज 86 नेम टू एजेंट आर डटी एक्सटी मतलब
एक तो पता है कि एक जिप फाइल है जिसका नाम
क्या है एजेंट आरटी एकटी टू एजेंट आड टी
एक्सटी तो एक काम करते हैं इसको भी हम
क्या करते हैं एक्सट्रैक्ट करते हैं बिन
वक के थ्रू एक्सट्रैक्ट करने के लिए हम
कमांड होती है बिन वक हाइन हाइन हाइन
एक्सट्रैक्ट हाइन हाइन एक्स्ट उसके
बाद आपकी इमेज का
नाम हिट एंटर यह
देखिए नाउ वी सक्सेसफुली गट द फाइल देखिए
यहां पर नेम अर्जेंट य सो सो ओके यहां पर
कुछ नहीं अभी एलस करते यह रहा यहां पर
हमें क्या मिला एक फाइल मिली होगी यह रही
यह रही यह रही क्यूटी पीएनजी एक्ससक्ड यह
रहा एक फाइल फोल्डर क्रिएट होग डायरेक्टरी
तो सीडी अंडरस्कोर कूटी यह रहा हिट एंटर
और एलस इसके अंदर चलते हैं देखो 365
365 जड लिप और
8702 जिप यहां पर हम एक जिप फाइल मिली है
ओके हमें क्या मिली है कि जिप फाइल मिली
है तो अभी हम इसको क्या करते हैं अनजिप
करेंगे तो अनजिप टूल का यूज करते हैं
अनजिप उसके बाद 87 ये रहा ये हिट एंटर नो
स्किपिंग स्किप कर रहे हैं तो वी आर नॉट
एबल टू अनजिप दिस फाइल अभी क्या
करें अभी क्या करें वी आर नॉट एबल टू
अनजिप दिस फाइल इन दैट केस व्हाट शुड वी
डू अभी हम क्या
करेंगे एक बार हम ग्राफिकल यूजर इंटरफेस
का और यूज करते हैं इसको अनजिप करने के
लिए नाउ गो टू योर
फोल्डर दिस इज वन दिस इज जिप फाइल एंड ये
देखो वाओ अभी क्या है ये रही बट ये अनजिप
हो गई चलो इसको ओपन करते हैं ये रहा इसको
ओपन करने की कोशिश करते हैं बट
नथिंग नथिंग नथिंग
नथिंग
पॉसिबल ओके ओके ी क्लोज
इट हम इसको एक काम करने की कोशिश करते हैं
एक्सट्रैक्ट करने की कोशिश करते
हैं एक्स्टेक्स्ट
हियर यर य
देखो अब हमने इसको एक्सट्रैक्ट किया तो
पासवर्ड मांगा
हमने इसको एक्स्टेक्स्ट किया तो इसने
पासवर्ड
मांगा
यस हमारे पास एक जिप फाइल है और यह
पासवर्ड प्रोटेक्टेड फाइल है ओके और हमें
क्या करना है इस पासवर्ड को फाइंड आउट
करना है और इस पासवर्ड को फाइंड आउट करने
के लिए हमें ब्रूट फोर्स करना पड़ेगा जिप
फाइल के ऊपर ओके अब ब्रूट फोर्स करने के
लिए मुझे कौन सा टूल यूज करना है अब यह भी
मुझे आप बताइए अगर मुझे एक जिप फाइल है
पासवर्ड प्रोटेक्टेड फाइल है अब मुझे उसके
ऊपर ब्रूट फोर्स ट्राई करना है पासवर्ड को
तो फाइंड आउट करना ही करना है तो कौन सा
टूल मैं यूज करूंगा प्रेफर टूल कौन सा
हमारा बताइए
बताइए बताइए बताइए
कुमावत आरयू सोर की एक टूल है जो आपके
पासवर्ड को कैक कर
देगा तो जो हाइड्रा बोल रहे
हैं कैसे और जो जोन बोल रहे हैं कैसे
दोनों को मुझे आंसर चाहिए कि मैं जोन से
कैसे कर सकता हूं या हाइड्रा से कैसे कर
सकता
हूं बताइए बताइए
एक पासवर्ड प्रोटेक्टेड फाइल है वी आर
श्यर तो हम कैसे कर सकते
हैं
बताइए अखिलेश राव इंटरव्यू में ऐसा जवाब
मत देना किसी
को अदर वाइज बहुत हसेंगे कि सर जोन इज द
बेस्ट टूल ट इज वई वी आर क्रैकिंग द
पासवर्ड विद द
जोन अरे भैया मैं पूछ रहा हूं कारण पूछ
रहा हूं कि हाइड्रा यूज कर रहे हैं तो
क्यों करेंगे रीजन चाहिए टूल आप लोगों ने
ब्लाइंड बोल दिया कि सर जोन यूज करेंगे
किसी ने बोल दिया सर हमारी यूज करेंगे
कारण क्या है दोनों का
अभी देखो सतगुरु जी बोल रहे जिप टू जोन का
यूज
करेंगे अरे कारण तो बताओ टूल यूज करने
का या इसका वॉक थ्रू देख के या किसी ने
इसको यूज किया होगा जस्ट सिंपली वही चिपका
रहे एक रीजन होगा ना इसको यूज करने
का कि मैं सर हाइड्रा यूज करूंगा तो इस
कारण से यूज करूंगा या मैं हाइड्रा यूज
नहीं करूंगा जोन यूज करूंगा तो इस कारण से
यूज
करूंगा चलिए आप लोग मुझे एक चीज और
बताइए ऑफलाइन ब्रूट फोर्सिंग और ऑनलाइन
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग सुनी है किसी
ने ऑफलाइन ब्रूट फोर्सिंग एंड ऑनलाइन
फोर्सिंग किसी ने सुना है या अगर सुना है
तो व्हाट इज द डिफरेंस बिटवीन ऑफलाइन
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग एंड ऑनलाइन ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग यार मेरे को जो जवाब चाहिए आप
लोग बता नहीं रहे हो आप लोगों से सीधा सा
सवाल पूछा है फिर से मैं पूछ रहा हूं कि
कौन सा टूल यूज करूंगा अगर जोन यूज करूंगा
तो क्यों यूज करूंगा उसका कारण बताइए अगर
मैं हाइड्रा यूज कर रहा हूं या हाइड्रा
नहीं यूज कर रहा हूं तो भी कारण बताइए
उसका दूसरा सवाल मैंने पूछा कि ऑफलाइन
ब्रूट फोर्सिंग और ऑनलाइन ब्रूट फोर्सिंग
में कोई डिफरेंस है या नहीं है अगर
डिफरेंस है तो क्या डिफरेंस है सीधे से
सवाल पूछे हैं आप मेरे को वर्किंग बता रहे
हो टूल की
आप लोग मुझे टूल की वर्किंग क्यों बता रहे
हो मैं आपसे एक सवाल पूछा
है जो यह मुझे वर्किंग बता रहे ना मैं
उनको बोल अभी वो आप बुरा मत मानना बट वॉक
थ्रो देख के मैं भी बता दूंगा कि मैं
क्यों यूज कर रहा बट अभी मुझे यह बताओ ना
कि आप लोग आंसर देक कॉमन सेंस यूज करो कि
हम क्यों कर रहे हैं क्यों क्यों क्यों आज
तो इसका वक थ्रो मिल गया रियल पेन
टेस्टिंग कर रहे होगे आप यह सवाल आपके
सामने फिर से खड़ा होगा फिर क्या
करोगे वेरी गुड कुमा कुमावत वेरी गुड
ऑफलाइन ब्रूट फोर्सिंग वी कैन यूज फॉर द
विच हैव डाउनलोड ऑलरेडी इन आवर
सिस्टम यह होती है आपकी ऑफलाइन ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग
देखिए फॉर योर काइंड इंफॉर्मेशन
हाइड्रा आप इस पर यूज नहीं कर सकते ओके
हाइड्रा एक सर्विस ब्रूट फोर्सिंग टूल है
वी कैन से ट ऑनलाइन ब्रूट फोर्सिंग टूल है
ओके बाकी जोन आप यूज कर सकते हो जोन का जो
बोल रहे आंसर सही है बट मैं जो आपसे पूछना
चाह रहा हूं उसका आंसर करने की बजाय आप
क्या कर रहे हो मेरे को उसकी वर्किंग बता
रहे हो अब मुझे आपसे ज्यादा अच्छे से
वर्किंग पता होगी उसकी ओके मुझे उसकी
वर्किंग नहीं जाननी थी मुझे पता करना था
कि क्यों यूज करेंगे बेसिकली जोन एक आपका
ऑफलाइन ब्रूट फोर्सिंग टूल है ओके क्योंकि
जो भी फाइल है वह अभी आपके सिस्टम में
प्रेजेंट है ओके और अगर वह सिस्टम में
प्रेजेंट है तो वह क्या है ऑफलाइन बट
फोर्सिंग के अंडर आती है अभी जोन द रिपर
क्या है
आपका एक प्रकार से ब्रूट ऑफलाइन ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग टूल हो गया यह आपका किसी भी फाइल
का पासवर्ड क्या कर सकता है क्रैक कर सकता
है चाहे आपकी ग ड्राइव की फाइल बैकअप फाइल
हो चाहे वो एड की बैकअप फाइल हो चाहे वह
आपके जो बिटकॉइन इनक्रिप्टेड वैलेट होता
है उसके भी फाइल्स है उसको भी ब्रूट फोर्स
ये कर सकता है इट कैन क्रैक एनीथिंग किसी
को भी ये क्रैक कर सकता है इतनी पावर है
जोन के अंदर जोन इज द गुड आंसर बट मुझे जो
आंसर चाहिए था आप लोग नहीं बता पा रहे थे
आंसर क्या था क्योंकि वह एक ऑफलाइन ब्रूट
फोर्सिंग टूल
है और फाइल्स हमारे सिस्टम पर प्रेजेंट है
और सिस्टम पर प्रेजेंट फाइल प हम क्या
करेंगे जितने भी ऑफलाइन बड फोर्स टूल है
उन्हीं को ही यूज करेंगे क्योंकि हाइड्रा
को यूज करेंगे तो हाइड्रा एक ऑनलाइन बड
फोर्सिंग टूल है एक सिंपल सा जवाब था यह
आपको देना था आप मेरे को वर्किंग समझा रहे
थे ओके लेकिन जोन के साथ भी प्रॉब्लम है
जोन के साथ प्रॉब्लम क्या है कि जोन
डायरेक्टली जो भी फाइल फॉर्मेट है उसके
साथ काम नहीं
करता उसको काम करने के लिए उसके इनपुट में
हैश वैल्यू चाहिए ओके जब भी उसको किसी भी
फाइल का पासवर्ड क्रैक करना है चाहे वो
पीडीएफ फाइल है चाहे वो आपकी जिप फाइल है
या कोई भी फाइल है वो डायरेक्टली फाइल
फॉर्मेट पे काम नहीं करता आपको सबसे पहले
उसको हैश में उसका हैश कन्वर्ट करना होगा
देन ओनली आप उस हैश को क्या करोगे एज ए
इनपुट पास करोगे जोन टूल के और जोन टूल
क्या करेगा वर्डलिस्ट को यूज करके उसका
पासवर्ड करेक्ट करेगा ओके यह इसकी
प्रॉब्लम है अब सबसे बड़ा सवाल यह खड़ा
होता है कि ओके अभी मेरे पास जिप फाइल है
तो जिप को मैं हैश फॉर्म में कैसे कन्वर्ट
करूंगा अगर मेरे पास पीडीएफ फाइल है अगर
मुझे पीडीएफ फाइल को भी क्या करना है उसके
पासवर्ड को क्रैक करना है तो उसके भी मैं
क्या करूंगा उसको हैश में कैसे कन्वर्ट
करूंगा यह हम कैसे कर सकते हैं क्या मुझे
खुद से कन्वर्ट करना होगा या इसके लिए कोई
फैसिलिटी अवेलेबल है
ओके तो बहुत लोग क्या कर रहे थे कि आंसर
सही दे रहे थे कौन सा कि सर हम जोन टू जिप
टू जोन यूज करेंगे तो भैया जिप टू जोन यूज
करेंगे लेकिन कहां से करेंगे क्यों करेंगे
वह आपको पता होना चाहिए तो अभी जो किसी भी
फाइल को क्या करना हैश में कन्वर्ट करने
की जो प्रोसेस है उसके लिए आपको अलग से
कोई भी टूल यूज करने की जरूरत नहीं
क्योंकि जो बा बाय डिफॉल्ट जब भी जोन द
रिप पर इंस्टॉल किया जाता है तो उसके अंदर
क्या होती है बहुत सारी स्क्रिप्ट होती है
जो आपका काम यह आसान कर देती है वह
स्क्रिप्ट आपको कहां पर देखने को मिलेगी
वो स्क्रिप्ट आपको देखने को मिलेगी आपकी
यूजर सेयर शायद जोन के
अंदर मैं पुराने रेफरेंस के हिसाब से देख
रहा
हूं ओके यह रहा
सीडी
यूजर
शेयर उसके बाद
जोन ओके हिट एंटर अभी हम एलस करते हैं तो
यह सारे सारे स्क्रिप्ट अवेलेबल है कुछ तो
पर्ल में होंगी और बाकी मैक्सिमम क्या
पाइथन में जैसे ये रहा वन पासवर्ड टू जोन
डॉट पाई उसके बाद आप देखोगे यहां पर यह
रहा अल्फा डट सीच आर देखिए य रहा अरूबा टू
जोन ड पाई देन उसके बाद हम बात करेंगे दिस
इज द अब जिप के लिए भी होगा इसमें देखो फज
ऑप्शन पील पर्ल के लिए भी है कॉन्फिन देन
देन देन वे द हमारे इसमें जो आप लोग जिक्र
कर रहे थे जिप टू जोन होगा जिप टू जोन
होगा और कहां पर होगा इट विलय देखते हैं
जड जड
जड एक जिप टू जोन होता है तो इसमें मिल
जाएगा आपको क्योंकि एक बहुत बड़ी फाइल है
तो जिप टू जोन का हम यूज
करेंगे हां फिर हम है को ब्रेक करेंगे तो
सबसे पहले हम यूज करेंगे कौन सा टूल यूज
करेंगे जिप टू जोन ओके तो जिप टू जोन के
लिए हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा अभी गो बैक अभी
प्रेजेंट वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी है हमारी रही
चलो इट्स ओके एंड नाउ वी आर बैक और एक बार
हम क्या करते हैं एक और नया टैब ओपन करते
हैं नया टैब और फिर से इसको जूम कर लेते
हैं एल एस अभी हम जिप टू जोन यहां भी यूज
करके देखते हैं एक बार एलस करते हैं
नाव
सीडी यह रहा ओके
यह
रहा
ना जिप टू जोन हम इसको हां अभी हम यूज
करेंगे जिप टू जोन उसके बाद हमारी जिप
फाइल का नाम उसके बाद हम क्या रखेंगे मा
जिप फाइल का नाम क्या है हमारा 87 यह रहा
87 जिप देन उसके बाद इसको रिडक करेंगे
हम रीडायरेक्ट हम इसका क्या करने वाले हैं
जिप हैश ओके जिप है के नाम से हम इसको
रखने वाले हैं हिट एंटर ओके इट विल
कन्वर्ट इन्होंने कन्वर्ट कर दिया अभी हम
क्या करते हैं फिर से चेक करते हैं यह रहा
जिप है नाम से एक फाइल हो गई अभी हम क्या
करेंगे जोन द रिपर का यूज़ करेंगे अगर
हमें जोन द रिपर को यूज करना है उसके लिए
हम डायरेक्टली यूज करते
हैं हां बिल्कुल वही शुभम तो अभी हम क्या
करेंगे जोन द रिपर टूल का यूज करेंगे हाइन
डायरेक्टली मैं जोन यूज करूंगा तो ये इसकी
हेल्प फाइल है जोन ऑप्शन पासवर्ड फाइल ओके
अभी हम क्या करने हैं जो बाय डिफॉल्ट ड
डिक्शनरी डायरेक्टरी सॉरी वर्डलिस्ट
अवेलेबल है जोन द रिपर टूल के अंदर हम उसी
का यूज करने वाले हैं
जोन उसके बाद यूज करने वाले जिप सस देन
उसके बाद हिट एंटर यह रहा इट विल टेक टाइम
इट विल क्रैक द पासवर्ड फॉर यू नाउ यह
देखिए इसका पासवर्ड आपको मिल गया जोन द
रिपर ने पासवर्ड क्रैक कर दिया इसका
पासवर्ड क्या है एलियन अब इस फाइल को हम
क्या करेंगे ओपन करेंगे तो कॉपी और अभी हम
चलते हैं किसके
अंदर फोल्डर के अंदर ओपन फोल्डर यह रहा
उसके अंदर गो टू डाउनलोड डाउनलोड से हम लब
फोर लब फोर के अंदर इसके अंदर और इसको हम
क्या करते हैं अभी एक्टैक करने की कोशिश
करते हैं
एक्स्टेक्स्ट कर देते हैं पेस्ट और ओके
नाउ रंग पासवर्ड
ओके पासवर्ड में क्या आ
गया वट ट
पासवर्ड हमारा एक बार देख लेते हैं हम ए
एल आईई
एन ओके
ओके हिट एंटर नाउ ी सक्सेसफुली टू एजेंट
आर डटी एक्सटी अभी हम इसको यही पर ओपन कर
लेते हैं देखिए टू एजेंट आर डटी एक्सटी
अभी देखो अभी यह क्या फाइल आ गया हमारे
सामने यह रहा एजेंट
सी वी नीड टू सेंड द पिक्चर
टू एक्स क्यू एक्स जे एल वाई टी यू एक्स
एज सून एस पॉसिबल बाय एजेंट आर अभी यह
क्या चीज है एक और नया चैलेंज हमारे
सामने एक और नया चैलेंज अब यह क्या चीज
है इसको देख के आपको क्या लगता है देखो
हमने एक चैलेंज से बाहर निकले कि ओके हमने
जिप फाइल को का पासवर्ड क्रैक कर लिया
इमेज एनालिसिस कर लिया फिर एक और नई चीज
हमारे पास आ गई एक और नई बला क्योंकि अभी
क्या कि लैब में चैलेंज पर चैलेंज आ रहे
हैं आपके सामने इसलिए एजेंट सुडो एक
इंटरेस्टिंग लैब है बहुत सारी चीजें आपको
सीखने को मिलती है बहुत सारे टूल्स आपको
देखने को मिलते हैं अभी एक और नया चैलेंज
आ गया तो अभी हम क्या करेंगे आपको क्या
देख के लगता है कि क्या वैल्यू हो सकती है
क्या हो सकता है
यह और कुछ जितने के जितने स्टूडेंट्स है
प्लीज आंसर मी मेरे साथ पार्टिसिपेट करो
साथ की साथ करने की बजाय मे साथ
पार्टिसिपेट करो अपना टाइम बचा लोगे मुझे
पता मेरे साथ कर कर के बट आप बिना
पार्टिसिपेट किए आपको नॉलेज नहीं होगी आप
अकेले से ट्राई करोगे किसी भी सीटीएफ को
तो दिस इज अ बेटर फॉर यू लेकिन अभी आप चैट
के थ्रू पार्टिसिपेट
करो यस बिल्कुल चैलेंज ही
चैलेंज मतलब कोई भी हैश वैल्यू या कन सेट
यूजर नेम बट ओके यूजर नेम भी हो सकता है
या यूजर नेम इनकोडेड भी हो सकता है या
इनक्रिप्टेड भी हो सकता है कोई पासवर्ड भी
हो सकता है
ना य पर सारी चांसेस है तो अभी हम इसको
क्या करते हैं चलो कॉपी कर लेते हैं
टर्मिनल पर चलते हैं और अभी हम क्या करने
की कोशिश करते हैं इसको अभी इसको एक बार
जूम कर य र जूम करते य रहा ना इसको अभी हम
क्या करते हैं एक बार एफटीपी करते हैं और
किसका किसका पासवर्ड ट्राई करते हम इसको
किसका पासवर्ड ट्राई करें बताओ इसको हम
पासवर्ड ट्राई करते हैं किसका जेम्स का ही
ठीक है जेम्स का ही पासवर्ड ट्राई करते
हैं एफटीपी
प नो नो नो नोनोनो इसका य था
एफटीपी ओके वट इ माय पासवर्ड अब कॉपी किया
तो फिर से कॉपी करना पड़ेगा यार ओके इट्स
ओके
यह
रहा कॉपी देन अगेन
यर
एफटीपी शिफ्ट व य रहा हिट एंटर
जेम्स ट एंटर और फिर से हम चलते हैं किसके
अंदर फाइल के अंदर यह रहा और यह फाइल ओपन
हमारी दिस वन इसको कॉपी करते हैं हम कॉपी
अगेन
पेस्ट हिट
एंटर लॉगिन फिल मतलब ये एफटीपी का पासवर्ड
नहीं है इट्स ओके अभी हम क्या करते हैं एक
बार क्रिस यहां पर कुछ लिखा हुआ था ना
आपको देखने को मिला हो रहा यहां पर एक
मिनट सी क्रिस हो सकता है तो एक काम करते
हैं हम क्रिस का पासवर्ड ट्राई करते हैं
इसको तो
एसएसए सी एच स्पेलिंग क्या थी सी एच आर आई
एस शायद मे बी ये
10164 214 हिट एंटर अब इसका पासवर्ड ट्राई
करते हैं इसको हम कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व हिट
एंटर मतलब यह इसका पासवर्ड भी नहीं है तो
अभी हम वी आर नॉट श्यर कि एक हैश फाइल है
या इनकोडेड फाइल है हम श्यर नहीं है तो जब
भी आप कोई भी सीटीएफ प्ले कर रहे हो या जब
भी आप रियल लाइफ में ऐसा कोई चैलेंज फेज
करते हो या इस तरह की कोई भी वैल्यू आपको
देखने को मिलती है तो वहां पर आपको नहीं
है आपके लिए एक बहुत ही एक अच्छा टूल है
जो काफी हेल्पफुल करता है कि यह चीज
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
एल्गोरिथम का यूज किया गया है या कौन सी
इनकोडेड एल्गोरिथम का यूज किया गया है यह
सारी इंफॉर्मेशन आपको मिल जाती है अगर इस
टाइप की कोई वैल्यू है तो यह और इस चीज को
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
करते हैं यह
रहा
साइबर साइबर सीवाई बी एस सीवाई ई बी एस सी
एच ई एफ होगा मे बी
यस दिस टूल दिस इज द टूल मे बी ओके य गेट
पेज है ना
शफ साइबर सेफ का अगर मेरे पास होगा
तो टूल होना चाहिए ना एक मिनट ओपन करके
देखते हैं इसको यस यह रहा यह आपका साइबर
सेफ एक टूल है जो काफी इंटरेस्टिंग टूल है
तो इस तरह के फॉर्मेट को आपको
आइडेंटिफिकेशन
इसको मैं जूम कर देता हूं ये रहा ये रहा
जूम किया और जो मेरी वैल्यू थी यहां पर
पेस्ट की दिस इज आवर वैल्यू अबी साइबर सेप
के अंदर एक इंटरेस्टिंग चीज है सबसे
इंटरेस्टिंग चीज क्या है कि यहां पर एक ये
एक क्या है कि काफी फीचर्स ये रहा है यहां
पर एक ये क्या है एक मैजिक कीवर्ड है अब
इसने बता दिया देखो फ्रॉम ये रहा यहां पर
क्लिक किया तो इसने बता दिया एक तो ये
यहां पर जब हिट किया तो इसने क्या फ्रॉम
बेस 64 मतलब ये एक बेस 64 इनकोडेड वैल्यू
है और जिसका जो टेक्स्ट वैल्यू क्या है
एरिया 51 जिसका टेक्स्ट वैल्यू क्या आपका
एरिया 51 और एरिया 51 अगर आपको समझ में आ
रहा है सुनने में अगर दोबारा लग रहा है कि
हमने कहीं पर एरिया 51 देखा था तो शायद आई
रिमेंबर या वी रिमेंबर की यह उसका पासवर्ड
था किसी फाइल का
ओके यह किसी फाइल का पासवर्ड था ओके अभी
यह इनक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म नहीं है आपकी
इनक्रिप्टेड फॉर्म नहीं है क्योंकि अगर
इंक्रिप्शन यूज किया होता तो यहां पर एक
की यूज हो रही होती डिक्रिप्ट करने के लिए
लेकिन यहां पर कोई भी यूज की भी यूज नहीं
की जा रही तो एक बार हमने हमें अब पता चल
जाता है कि अगर कोई भी फॉर्म इनकोडेड
फॉर्म है और किस टाइप का इनकोडेड फॉर्म
यूज किया बेस 64 बेस 32 या बेस 58 खास कर
के ये जो इनकोडेड है वेबसाइट के द्वारा
यूज किया जाता है कि जब द डाटा वन प्लेस
टू अनदर प्लेस क्या किया जाता है शिफ्ट
किया जाता है या ट्रांसफर किया जाता है तो
ज्यादातर वहां पर इनकोडिंग यूज की जाती है
तो जब आपको पता चल जाता है कि व्ट टाइप ऑफ
इंफॉर्मेशन या व्ट टाइप ऑफ इनकोडिंग तो आप
वहां पर क्या कर सकते हो सीधा डायरेक्टली
डिकोड करने की कोशिश करते हो इंक्रिप्शन
के केस में आपके पास की होनी चाहिए बट
इनकोडिंग के केस में आप डिकोड ट्राई कर
सकते हो बट आपके पास ये इंफॉर्मेशन है तो
देन यहां तक हमने सब कुछ कर लिया इट्स ओके
वेरी वेल अभी फिर से हम चलते हैं देखो अभी
हो गया तो एरिया 51 यहां पर इससे ज्यादा
कोई इंफॉर्मेशन नहीं थी हमारे लिए तो इट्स
ओके चलो इसको हम एग्जिट करते हैं हिट एंडर
यह रहा तो हमने दोनों इमेज को एनालाइज
किया एक इमेज में क्या था कि जो पीएनजी थी
पीएनजी में किसका पासवर्ड था जेपीजी का
पासवर्ड था ओबवियसली क्योंकि हिटन ट्रायल
करना चाहिए था हमें इट्स ओके हमने दो
इमेजेस थ्रोली एक्सेस कर ली अभी अभी हमारे
पास क्या एक्सेस है मशीन का हमारे पास
मशीन का एक्सेस है यह रहा यह हमारे पास
मशीन का एक्सस है यह रहा यह रहा तो अभी हम
क्या
करेंगे हमने x एक्सप्लोइटेशन कर लिया
वैलिड क्रेडेंशियल के था और हमें पर्सेंट
की जरूरत नहीं क्योंकि हमने यहां पर
एक्सप्लोइटेशन अभी कर लिया तो अभी हमारा
जो फेज स्टार्ट होता है पोस्ट
एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज स्टार्ट होता है तो
पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन फेज में सबसे पहले
क्या होता है आपका लोकल एन्यूमरेशन होता
है तो लोकल एन्यूमरेशन मैं आपको जल्दी
सिखाऊंगा उसके बाद आपकी फाइल ट्रांसफर
होती है ऑप्शनल होता है प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन होता है हमें यहां पर प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन करना है अभी ओके प्रिविलेज
एस्केलेशन करने के लिए आपको पता है अभी
यहां पर एक चीज है यूजर फ्लैग आपके पास है
अभी एलियन ऑटो स्पाई ड जेपीजी फाइल है य
एक फाइल है अभी मुझे क्या करना है इसका भी
स्टक एलिसिस करना है इसका स्टस कैसे कर
सकता हूं
मैं बताइए इसका टैग एनालिसिस कैसे कर सकता
हूं
मैं अगर मुझे इसका स्टग एनालिसिस करना है
नोट जेपीजी फाइल है मुझे इसका स्टैक
एनालिसिस करना है तो मैं कैसे करूंगा आपके
सामने जूम कर दिया क्योंकि अभी हम क्या है
सर्वर के ऊपर है और शायद हमें नहीं लगता
कि सर्वर के ऊपर बिन वक या एजिप टूल जैसे
टूल एग्जिट करते ह जैसे हम क्या करते हैं
एजिप टूल टेंटर करके देखते हैं तो एजिप
टूल है ही नहीं मतलब कमांड नॉट फाउंड अगर
बिन वक है तो तब भी हम क्या कर सकते हैं
हमारे पास तब भी हमारे पास यह भी कमांड है
नहीं तो मैं एलियन ड अंडरकोट स्पाई ड
जेपीजी फाइल का
कैसे स्टैग एनालिसिस
करूंगा ओके अगर मुझे इसको अपनी मशीन पर
लाने के लिए भी मैं जिस सिचुएशन में हूं
तो अपनी मशीन पर कैसे लेकर
आऊंगा ओके वेरी गुड कि आपने बोला सर हमें
अपनी मशीन पर डाउनलोड करना होगा तो हम
अपनी मशीन पर डाउनलोड कैसे कर सकते हैं
अभी प्रेजेंट सिनेरियो में जल्दी मैं आपको
एक टॉपिक समझाऊ जब व रिवर्स सेल रिवर्स
सेल का एक टॉपिक होता है जब हम रिवर्स सेल
लेते हैं ना वो टॉपिक होता है तो रिवर्स
सेल कैसे लेते हैं जैसे हम नेट कट होता है
नेट कट के थ्रू या और भी टूल्स के थ्रू या
फाइल ट्रांसफर करनी होती है तो हम कैसे
करते हैं वो मैं आपको समझाऊं सेल को
अपग्रेड करना या फाइल ट्रांसफर करनी है तो
मैं कैसे करूंगा बट अभी सिनेरियो में हम
कैसे एक्सेस सर्वर के ऊपर सर्वर की फाइल
को
अपने लिनक्स के ऊपर डाउनलोड कर सकते हैं
या लेके आ सकते
हैं बताइए बताइए कॉपी नहीं होगा कॉपी नहीं
होगा नहीं गेट कैसे करोगे यार यू आर
इने मशीन का सेल आपके
पास बताइए बताइए इ देर एनी
वे कि हम इसको अपनी मशीन पर लेकर आ सकते
हैं
क्योंकि हम एक वैलिड क्रेडेंशियल के साथ
हैं लिमिटेड एक्सेस के साथ तो हम कैसे
अपनी मशीन के ऊपर इस फाइल को लेकर आ सकते
हैं फरदर स्टैग एनालिसिस के
लिए शुभम बोल रहे हैं हेल्प कमांड का यूज
करो ओके देखो लो अभी देखो
देखो हेल्प कमांड से क्या निकाल सकते हो
आप
इधर
शुभम बिना सोचे बोल देते
हो एचटीटीपी सर्वर सेटअप करोगे आप इसके
ऊपर आपका परमिशन है
यू आर वेरी लीस्ट
सुडो फन एल चलो हम अपनी परमिशन देख लेते
हैं इसका पासवर्ड था
हमारा
कर यह हमारी परमिशन
है
ओनली ओनली दिस इज आवर
परमिशन बताइए
मैं इस परे सर्वर सेटअप कर सकता
हूं क्या बोल रहे हैं राजू बोल रहे हैं सर
हम मशीन के अंदर है तो हम एलिफ और स्टैग
हाइट यूज करें ओके कैसे करोगे भैया
मशीन का एडमिन राइट ऑब्टेन करने के लिए तो
प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन करना होगा बट अब हम
कैसे कर सकते हैं
देखिए अभी आपका कनेक्शन किसके थ्रू है
एसएसएस के थ्रू कनेक्शन है तो एसएसएस में
एक कमांड होती है
एससीपी किसी को पता है एससीपी कमांड होती
है
एससीपी उस कमांड की हेल्प से आप फाइल
ट्रांसफर कर सकते हो वेरी
सिक्योर ठीक है क्योंकि एसएसएस भी फाइल
ट्रांसफर कर सकता है किसी को पता है
ओके तो उसके लिए हमें कमांड होती है
एससीपी उसके बाद एससीपी कमांड क्या कर
सकती है आप अपने किसी भी रिमोट मशीन से
लोकल मशीन में या लोकल मशीन से रिमोट मशीन
में फाइल ट्रांसफर कर सकते हो या किसी
रिमोट से रिमोट में भी कर सकते हो आप अगर
वह एक ही नेटवर्क में है या ओके या उनका
एसएसएस कनेक्शन एस्टाब्लिशड
टू रिमोट रिमोट टू लोकल लोकल टू रिमोट ट
तीनों तरीके से आप क्या कर सकते हो एससीपी
कमांड की हेल्प से फाइल ट्रांसफर कर सकते
हो इट इज अ वेरी वेरी इंपोर्टेंट टॉपिक
इसलिए मैं आपको बोलता हूं कि आपको एसएसएस
का टॉपिक बिल्कुल क्लियर होना चाहिए कि
एसएसए कैसे काम करता है एसएसए अगर आपको
सेटअप करना पड़ जाए तो कैसे आप सेटअप कर
सकते हो उसका हार्ड निंग कैसे कर सकते हो
अगर उसको सिक्योर फाइल ट्रांसफर करनी है
तो कैसे कर सकते हो यह सारी चीजें आपको
पता होनी चाहिए पहले से ही इसलिए मैं डे
वन से बोल रहा हूं कि आप
रि मोटली कैसे फाइल को ट्रांसफर करूंगा वो
भी मैं आपको तरीके सिखाऊंगा लेकिन आज का
एक ही तरीका आपको बता रहा हूं मैं एससीपी
कमांड की हेल्प से या जो एसएस टनलिंग है
उसकी हेल्प से आप क्या कर सकते हो फाइल
ट्रांसफर कर सकते हो कैसे एससीपी कमांड
देन उसके बाद क्या करोगे जेम्स यूजर नेम
देन उसके बाद रेट 10 डॉट 10 डॉट मेरा आईपी
एड्रेस क्या है अभी मैं चेक कर लेता हूं
एक
बार 164
देन उसके बाद मेरा आईपी एड्रेस 164 के बाद
है 214 214 ओके यह देन मैं क्या करूंगा
जिस फाइल को मुझे ट्रांसफर करना है मेरी
फाइल कहां पर है मेरी फाइल मेरी होम
डायरेक्टरी के अंदर अगर नहीं पता तो मैं
चेक कर सकते हो तो मेरी फाइल सेमी कॉलन
देन मेरी होम डायरेक्टरी के अंदर होम देन
उसके बाद कौन सी है
जेम्स जेम्स देन उसके बाद
मेरा फाइल नेम क्या फुल पाथ एलियन जो
मेरी अभी यहां पर टैब काम करेगा नहीं तो
हमें क्या करना पड़ेगा अभ इसको थोड़ा
स्क्रोल डाउन करना पड़ेगा अभी आप लोगों ने
वो करवा दिया मैं एक बार इसको एलस करता
हूं यहां पर सॉरी एलस अभी मुझे एक काम
करना पड़ेगा इधर यह रहा इसको कॉपी करना
पड़ेगा कॉपी
एससीपी जेम्स
रेट 10 ड 10 डॉट डॉट उसके बाद आप यूज
करोगे 164
214 देन कॉलन उसके बाद होम प्रेजेंट
वर्किंग डायरेक्टरी जेम्स उसके बाद
कंट्रोल शिफ्ट व एलियन डट अभी मुझे कहां
पर ट्रांसफर करना है मुझे अपने होम
डायरेक्टरी में ट्रांसफर करना है
होम कौन सा मेरा
r78 t9 इसके अंदर मुझे क्या करना है
ट्रांसफर करना है यह रहा उसके अंदर मैं
क्या कर दूंगा र कर दूंगा तो मैं ऐसे कर
सकता हूं अभी मैं क्या कर ट एंटर देखिए यह
पासवर्ड मांगेगा यस फाइल ट्रांसफर पासवर्ड
मेरा क्या है
हैकर हैकर
रूल्स व आपका एस्केलेशन मार्क्स य रहा हिट
एंटर वि स नो सच फाइल ओके ओके ओके ओके अभी
हम क्या करते हैं फिर मेरे जो कनेक्शन है
मैं किसके साथ कनेक्शन मुझे कनेक्शन चेक
करना पड़ेगा प्रेजेंटली तो मैं इसको
कनेक्शन को ब्रेक नहीं कर सकता तो मैं एक
काम कर देता हूं इसको
मैं
डॉट
नाउ नाउ वी सक्सेसफुली हमने जो करंट
डायरेक्टरी है उसमें सक्सेसफुली ट्रांसफर
कर लिया है अभी मैं चेक करूंगा तो यह मेरी
डायरेक्टरी कौन सी हो सकती है मोस्ट
प्रोबेबली अभी मैं कनेक्शन के एक बार कर
देता हूं एग्जिट
अभी के लिए इसको क्या करता हूं एग्जिट यह
देखो यह लब फोर के अंदर हूं सीडी यह आ गई
मेरी यहां पर आई होगी कहां पर फाइल होगी
नहीं नहीं नहीं नहीं होम डायरेक्टरी ओके
कहां पर मैं करंट
डायरेक्टरी वे शड आई ट्रांसफर
इट एलियन ड
जेपीजी नहीं मिली है तो अभी हम क्या करते
फिर से
एड जीपीजी अभी हम क्या करते हैं बाहर चलते
हैं
पहले
ओके अभी हम इसके अंदर ऐड करते हैं चलो और
अभी हम फिर से कनेक्शन क्रिएट करते हैं और
फाइल को ट्रांसफर करते हैं तो कैसे
करेंगे एसएसए
परमिशन
डिनाइड ओके ओके
ओके तो एक बार हम फिर से ट्राई करते इसको
तो आप इस तरीके से कमांड को वैसे यूज कर
सकते हो तो मुझे फाइल को फाइंड आउट करना
पड़ेगा आज हम काफी डिले कर गए क्लास में
तो यहां से कंटिन्यू करेंगे क्लास में तो
वैसे आप लोगों के लिए टास्क क्या है सूडो
हाइन एल इस तरीके से आप इस एक तो क्या काम
क्या आपका एससीपी कमांड को यूज करना है
एससीपी कमांड को यूज करके आपको क्या करना
है आपको जो स्टैग सस करना है किसका एलियन
ऑट स्पाई ड जेपीजी फाइल का आपको स्टैग
एलिसिस करना है दूसरा ये आपके पास परमिशन
है तो मुझे इसका प्रिविलेज एलेशन करना है
रूट एक्सेस करना है तो आप लोग खुद से
ट्राई कीजिए आप इसका रूट एक्सेस ले पा रहे
हो या नहीं है ले पा रहे हो मैं इसके ऊपर
क्या करूंगा नेक्स्ट जो सेशन रहेगा उसमें
मैं इस पर पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन परफॉर्म
करूंगा पोस्ट एक्सप्लोइटेशन में दो चीजें
सिखाऊंगा एक पहली चीज सिखाऊंगा मैं खास
करते खास कर प्रिविलेज एलेशन करने से पहले
हम क्या करेंगे एक्सप्लोइटेशन करना
सिखाऊंगा आपको मैं उसके अंदर भी प्रज
एलेशन में भी कि आप एक्सप्लोइट कैसे कर
सकते हो और एक्सप्लोइट करने के लिए
आपको कौन-कौन से कहां-कहां से आप क्या कर
सकते हो उसका एक्सप्लोर ढूंढ सकते हो ओके
तो आप खुद से ट्राई कीजिए एक बार अगर आप
एक्सप्लोइट कर पा रहे हो तो अच्छी बात है
अदर वाइज आई विल टीच यू सेशन का नाम और
कुछ रहेगा वैसे हमने इनिशियल एक्सेस ले
लिया है मशीन के अंदर अ विद क्रेडेंशियल
बट हमारा पोस्ट एक्सप्लोरेशन फेज स्टार्ट
हो गया है पोस्ट एक्सप्लोरेशन फेज के बहुत
सारे स्टेजेस होते हैं आठ स्टेज होती हैं
जिनमें से हम दो या तीन स्टेज अभी सीखेंगे
उसके बाद धीरे-धीरे सारी की सारी स्टेज हम
सीख लेंगे तो सभी कर लोगे
इसको यार आप मैं नहीं कर सकता क्योंकि
मुझे और भी काम रहते हैं मुझे इसलिए मैं
टाइम लिमिटेड रहता है मेरे पास एक्सटेंड
करने के लिए मेरे पास सच में नहीं कर
पाऊंगा आई एम सॉरी फॉर दैट इसलिए इतना ही
टाइम लिमिट है कि मैं डेढ़ घंटा पढ़ा पाता
हूं क्योंकि मुझे फरदर और भी बहुत सारे
काम रहते
हैं तो प्लीज
ओके तो आप एक बार खुद से ट्राई कीजिए और
एससीपी कमांड को मैंने आपको हिंट दे दिया
है हो सकता कि मैं एससीपी कमांड थोड़ा सा
काफी टाइम बाद यूज कर तो गलत भी यूज कर
रहा हूं तो आप एक बार इसका चिट चट देख
लेना तो उससे आपको आईडिया हो जाएगा एससीपी
कमांड से आप इसको अपने लोकल मशीन में
डाउनलोड कर सकते हो क्रेडेंशियल आप जेम्स
के यूज करोगे और जो आपके पास एक यह है ना
कि बिन बैस आप सुडो के साथ इसको रन कर
सकते हो तो आप इसको इसके ऊपर आप क्या आपको
क्या करना है प्रिज एस्केलेशन करना है
जीटीएफ य बिन की हेल्प से ओके वो आपको
ट्राई करना है अदर वाइज मैं आपको करवाऊंगी
ही करवाऊंगी डोंट वरी तो आज का सेशन हम
एंड करते हैं तो किसी शायद कोई क्वेरी हो
तो मुझसे पूछ सकते
हैं तो श तो कर लोगे मैंने आपको चैलेंज
बताया हां जीटीएफ बन की हेल्प से एक बार
आप ट्राई करना इसको प्रिविलेज एस्केलेशन
दूसरा आपको स्टैग एनालिसिस करना है इस
इमेज के ऊपर भी वो हम करेंगे नहीं इमेज आप
खुद से कर सकते हो ओके हो
जाएगा ओके थैंक यू बाय बाय एंड गुड नाइट
और सी यू फॉर नेक्स्ट सेशन अगले सेशन में
हम
मिलेंगे ओके तो बाय बाय एंड थैंक यू गुड
नाइट यह आप लोगों का टास्क है आप इस पर
मेहनत कीजिए फाइंड आउट कीजिए इसको
एक्सप्लोइट कीजिए और इसमें सक्सेसफुली रूट
एक्सेस लेना है आपको रूट फ्लैग ढूंढना है
इफ यू
आर लकी इफ यू आर सक्सेसफुल देन वेरी गुड
आप लैग को लैब को सबमिट कीजिए और मेरे को
लिंक दिन पर भेज दीजिए डेफ इस ग्रुप को
लिंक दिन पर भेज दीजिए कि आपने य लैब
सॉल्व कर ली है और अदर वाइज आई विल
एक्सप्लेन एक कांसेप्ट है जो काफी
इंपोर्टेंट कांसेप्ट है जो मुझे अभी
धीरे-धीरे एक्सप्लेन करने हैं मेरा मोटो
यह नहीं है कि मैं सब आपको ट्राई हैक मी
के सीटीएफ परफॉर्म करवाऊं ट्राई हैक मी के
सीटीएफ परफॉर्म करने का तरी मैं इसलिए
लेता हूं मैं ताकि उसके थ्रू आपको
कांसेप्ट पढ़ा सकूं क्योंकि दज आर द बेस्ट
वे कि किसी के फंडामेंटल कांसेप्ट क्लियर
करवाने हो या आपके जो टूल्स हैं वह क्लियर
करवाने हो इससे साथ ही साथ आपके किसी भी
पन टेस्टिंग एग्जाम की तैयारी हो जाती है
ओके तो बाय बाय थैंक यू गुड नाइट फिर
मिलेंगे नेक्स्ट सेशन में जल्दी तो तब तक
के लिए आप लोग रिवाइज कीजिए और जो टास्क
दिए जाते हैं उनको फुलफिल कीजिए
थोड़ी-थोड़ी रिसर्च कीजिए और एक चीज है
कॉन्फिडेंस बनाइए जो सवाल पूछा जाता है
उसका आंसर उसी तरीके से देने की कोशिश कर
कीजिए उसको एक्सटेंड करने की कोशिश ना
करें जिससे आपको एक अच्छी आदत पड़ेगी
इंटरव्यू को झेलने की तो बाय-बाय थैंक यू